I think that Star Wars is great because
it can be taken on a lot of different
levels it can be taken very seriously
and I mean people you know based like
the meaning of their lives around it it
can be taken very lightly to it I am
Queen Amidala
I was very excited about it at the
prospect of doing this film when when
they first offered it to me but I sat
down for a while and thought about it it
took me a few weeks to decide but doing
this film because it's a huge commitment
to sign on for three films when you're
14 which really means you're giving up
you know 10 years of your life and
dedicating it to to acting and and
that's a hard decision to make when
you're that young I think it's a really
cool role model for girls it's really
exciting to see someone who's young and
smart and uses her her female
characteristics to help her be a good
leader you know
well not condone a course of action that
will lead us to war George suggested
that I changed my voice and accent for
it for the role so that it would really
distinguish between you know other
things that I that I do in the film so
we worked on making my voice deeper and
and also you know changing the accent
and we kind of went for something
unidentifiable that was just kind of you
know not really British not really
American not really European just kind
of a mix of everything just very regal
I knew the advantage of no-confidence
the problem screams tough easy what was
the worst thing about the blue screen
and the best thing about well the best
thing about it was that it was really a
really good exercise for the imagination
and and it's a challenge you know acting
that way because because you really have
to visualize in your mind what's going
on around you and it's a much bigger
task than just in normal than just
normal acting and as far as bad things
just the main thing is that it's much
harder it's you really don't you really
have to use your imagination and it
really it challenges you and and
sometimes you can't imagine because it's
not even your own imagination it's like
George's imagination and you can't
really get inside someone else's head
very closely George would try and help
us but I had no idea it would come out
the way I did I was sitting there at the
screening just just flipping out over
over what everything looked like the
visuals
[Music]